[Música]
la corrupción desvía el 5% del producto
bruto interno a nivel mundial que
equivale a 4 millones de millones de
dólares que van para el beneficio de
unos cuantos según el fondo monetario
internacional entre 1.5 y 2 millones de
millones de dólares se pagan al año en
sobornos
la última encuesta de ipsos-apoyo en el
perú ha revelado que el 57 por ciento de
los peruanos consideramos que la
corrupción es el principal problema del
país por encima de la inseguridad
ciudadana la falta de trabajo y la falta
de educación
no es casual entonces que los últimos
cinco presidentes o hayan estado presos
por corrupción o investigados o prófugos
por esa misma razón al punto que cuando
vino el papá hace poco se preguntaba qué
pasa en el perú que todos sus
presidentes terminan presos por
corrupción
cuando hablamos de corrupción nos
estamos refiriendo a esa situación en la
que se privilegia el beneficio personal
de uno y los suyos a costa del bien
común la corrupción profundiza la
pobreza incrementa la desigualdad y
además tiene un impacto en la
gobernabilidad por eso hemos visto caer
gobiernos como el de dilma rousseff en
el brasil o el del propio kuczynski aqui
en el peru lamentablemente en nuestro
caso la corrupción no es un problema
coyuntural tiene raigambres históricas
sistémicas y estructurales
viene desde la época de la colonia en la
que se implantó una matriz clientelista
basada en el intercambio de favores
desde el poder a cambio de beneficios o
dinero una expresión de eso es cómo se
elegían los virreyes para venir a esta
parte del mundo no se elegía a aquellos
que habían cumplido meritocrática mente
una mejor función en españa' sino aquel
que podía pagar más por el cargo quien
luego venía a recuperar su inversión
entre comillas a la brevedad posible'
esto generó que la corrupción se
enquistará en las estructuras mismas del
poder se desarticularán y desviar a
desnaturalizar a las políticas públicas
y el estado se pusiera al servicio de
unos cuantos a costa de las mayorías
la corrupción puede consistir en actos
cotidianos donde se mueven menores
cuantías pero también existe un fenómeno
muy presente en estos días llamado gran
corrupción
la gran corrupción implica que autores
con poder movilizan inmensas cantidades
de recursos que terminan impactando
negativamente en el goce de los derechos
fundamentales de los ciudadanos más
vulnerables tenemos muchos ejemplos de
eso en los últimos tiempos el caso del
ex presidente de egipto mubarak acusada
de robar 50 mil millones de dólares
cuando estuvo en el poder el caso del
expresidente de ucrania yanukóvich
acusado de haber robado 12 mil millones
de dólares el caso del primer ministro
de malasia najib hoy preso investigado
por haber robado 4 mil millones de
dólares durante su gobierno el caso de
puyol el ex presidente de cataluña y su
familia investigados por haber robado
aproximadamente tres mil millones de
euros y entre otros muchos casos de gran
corrupción el que remeció y de américa
latina el caso la baja pto que ha
impactado en 11 países de nuestra región
y que se estima que puede llegar hasta
50 mil millones de dólares
por concepto de corrupción y es que la
corrupción la gran corrupción moviliza
inmensas cantidades de dinero el banco
mundial calcula que al año se evaden
impuestos un millón de millones de
dólares
se imaginan ustedes lo que se podría
resolver en términos sociales sólo con
una parte de ese dinero sin duda se
resolverían los grandes problemas de la
humanidad se podría desterrar el hambre
del mundo proveer servicios de salud a
quienes no lo tienen educación a quienes
no tienen acceso a una formación básica
y que tengan acceso a agua potable
desagüe vivienda digna aquellos que hoy
día viven en condiciones de pobreza o
extrema pobreza
pero la corrupción no sólo se mide en
términos de cifras o índices económicos
la corrupción tiene una incidencia y la
gran corrupción en particular sobre las
vidas concretas de los seres humanos la
corrupción mata cuando colapsa un
edificio en bangladesh y mueren 1600
trabajadoras textiles y se hace la
investigación de qué ha pasado ahí y se
descubre que eso ocurrió porque alguien
soborno a las autoridades para construir
construir ese edificio sobre un terreno
que no era aparente y sin las
especificaciones técnicas que exigía la
ley esas 1600 mujeres son muertes
directas generadas por la corrupción
cuando en el perú dos jóvenes jovi
huertas y jorge luís herrera son
encerrados en un contenedor para
explotarlos laboralmente con un candado
exterior y mueren asfixiados en el
contexto de un incendio y luego se sabe
que eso fue posible porque alguien
soborno al inspector municipal
que permite esa situación esos dos
muchachos son consecuencias directas de
la corrupción cuando hace unos años en
mesa redonda explotó un mercado ilegal
de fuegos artificiales y murieron más de
400 personas y después se supo que eso
pudo ser posible porque alguien pagó a
las autoridades para que se hagan de la
vista gorda y permitan el comercio
ilegal de esa mercadería esas más de 400
personas son víctimas directas de la
corrupción la corrupción entonces no
sólo son indicadores mata enferma impide
la educación y el acceso a una vida
digna
hace pocos días hemos leído la noticia
de que el hijo del presidente de guinea
ecuatorial teodoro obiang fue detenido
en el brasil portando una bolsa con 16
millones de dólares en efectivo relojes
y joyas
que evidentemente han sido robadas por
la dictadura de su padre que viene
saqueando el país hace muchos años y en
ecuatorial es un país rico en petróleo
debería tener un ingreso per cápita
equivalente a 12 dólares sin embargo dos
terceras partes de la población viven en
extrema pobreza con menos de 70 centavos
de dólar al día
esto tiene evidentemente un reflejo la
corrupción me refiero en los niveles de
pobreza de un país y ya que hablamos de
pobreza el perú no es ajeno a esta
situación según el instituto de
estadística nacional en el 2016 uno de
cada cinco peruanos vive en condiciones
de pobreza
estudios se han revelado que en el 2013
se robaron 10 mil millones de soles
equivalentes a 30 veces el presupuesto
del programa que una más un programa
social para ayudar a niños por debajo de
los 3 años en situación de pobreza y
vulnerabilidad
la comisión presidencial de integridad
que se formó el año pasado concluyó
entre otras varias situaciones que en el
2016 se sustrajo del perú por vías de
corrupción 12 mil 600 millones de soles
equivalentes al 10 por ciento del
presupuesto nacional
se imaginan los problemas sociales que
hubiéramos podido resolver con esas
cifras y otro reflejo de eso es que la
contraloría general de la república en
el período 2013 2016 denunció a 5 mil 60
funcionarios públicos penalmente por
haber cometido delitos de corrupción más
escalofriante todavía es saber que 17 de
los 23 gobernadores de este país o están
presos o procesados por casos de
corrupción y cuando vamos a la cifra de
los alcaldes más del 92% de los alcaldes
distritales o municipales están en la
misma situación
es una situación abrumadora que podemos
hacer frente a esto
cuál es el reto que se nos presenta por
delante este es un signo inevitable
que sepamos la corrupción no se
transmite por genética los peruanos no
somos más corruptos que otros porque
somos chicha o somos cholos o comemos
ceviche la corrupción en este país
obedece a causas claramente
identificables somos un país mal armado
que se ha construido sobre una serie de
prácticas inadecuadas que han terminado
poniéndonos en la situación en la que
estamos el día de hoy
si cambiáramos esta actitud que se
debate entre el fatalismo y el cinismo y
pensáramos que es posible salir de esta
tendencia de decir bueno el perú es así
los peruanos somos así votaré por un
candidato que roba pero alguna obra hará
y transitamos hacia una cultura de la
integridad y a ellos le agregamos por
supuesto políticas adecuadas de
prevención y persecución de la
corrupción la situación les aseguro
puede cambiar y hay ejemplos en el mundo
a nivel internacional está el caso de
hong kong considerada una de las
ciudades más corruptas del mundo cuando
era colonia inglesa y en la que gracias
a la creación de una comisión
anticorrupción que trabajó en prevención
educación y ruptura de rutinas corruptas
se logró reducir dramáticamente la
corrupción en esa jurisdicción hoy día
hong kong ocupa el puesto número 3 en el
ranking de países de transparencia
internacional la coalición más grande en
materia de corrupción lo que quiere
decir que ya no es un problema
a su día a día su desarrollo su
viabilidad
otro ejemplo más dramático es el de
botsuana en el áfrica sub-sahariana
todos sabemos las crisis que pasan en
términos de democracia y corrupción los
países africanos botsuana es un país
rico en diamantes pero allí en lugar de
que los líderes han tenido cuatro buenos
gobiernos sucesivamente se robaran el
dinero de los ingresos los diamantes
para su propio beneficio actuaron con
visión de país se distribuyeron la
riqueza y lograron controlar los niveles
de corrupción pública hoy día botsuana
ocupa el puesto 34 de 180 países del
mundo muy por encima del perú por
supuesto si miramos a nivel interno
también hay ejemplos que demuestran que
los peruanos podemos construir en
integridad uno de esos ejemplos es el
banco central de reservas una
institución que desde su fundación hasta
la fecha se ha mantenido por encima del
promedio nacional en materia de
integridad institucional y eso porque se
creó una cultura que fue transmitiéndose
funcionarial mente institucionalmente
independientemente de cuál fuera el
gobierno de turno
otro ejemplo es el de la sunat la
superintendencia nacional de
administración tributaria la agencia que
colecta impuestos la zona pasó de ser
hace tres décadas de una institución
súper corrupta a ser hoy día una
institución que está también por encima
del promedio nacional y eso ocurrió
porque hace tres décadas llegó un
funcionario que venía del bcr
precisamente manuel estela quien trajo
un modelo de desarrollo institucional y
predicó con el ejemplo con liderazgo y
con honestidad eso cambió totalmente la
cultura institucional en sunat
esto demuestra que es efectivamente
posible hacer un cambio sustancial si es
que se afirma el liderazgo se transita
por la vida de una cultura de integridad
y por supuesto se aplican las políticas
adecuadas
no hay que ser muy avispado para darse
cuenta que hoy día estamos viviendo una
gran crisis de corrupción probablemente
la más relevante después la del año 2000
en pocas semanas y meses hemos visto
caer a un gobierno democráticamente
elegido
hemos observado como una investigación
al crimen organizado termina con la
renuncia del presidente del poder
judicial la desaparición del consejo
nacional de la magistratura genera una
crisis sin precedente en el ministerio
público y además en los últimos días
también hemos conocido que una corte ha
ordenado la vuelta a prisión de un ex
presidente de la república y se ha
dispuesto en esta semana la detención de
la principal líder esa oposición acusada
de haber recibido fondos de la
corrupción para financiar su campaña
electoral
como toda gran crisis esta situación
también genera una tremenda ventana de
oportunidad en la mañana hemos escuchado
la metáfora de los trenes si dejamos
pasar este tren probablemente no
tendremos otra oportunidad para poder
cambiar las cosas y en ese sentido dado
que la corrupción no es solamente un
problema del sector público
donde hay que tener buenos funcionarios
también desde el sector privado se
pueden aportar soluciones importantes
los empresarios que han acumulado por su
propia actividad tecnología innovación
conocimiento y por supuesto recursos son
actores fundamentales si es que pueden
aportar desde una cultura de la
integridad y el cumplimiento si los
empresarios que se ven atacados desde la
corrupción en vez de conformarse con la
situación fueran a sus gremios a
enfrentar colectivamente esta situación
en alianza con buenos funcionarios y
ciudadanos organizados probablemente
otra sería la situación los negocios
privados permiten generar cadenas de
proveedores y clientes yo no voy a
comprar tus servicios si es que tú no
tienes los estándares de honestidad que
yo exijo y eso puede generar
efectivamente una dinámica virtuosa que
produzca un cambio sustancial en esta
materia
finalmente la pregunta es que podemos
hacer los demás los ciudadanos de a pie
lo que estamos aquí sentados
lamentablemente la realidad indica según
la encuesta de proética que es el
capítulo peruano de transparencia
internacional que se viene haciendo hace
más de 10 años que el 75% de los
peruanos somos indiferentes frente a la
corrupción nos da igual hacemos broma de
ello es una forma de vivir y de
movilizarse socialmente si los
ciudadanos redujéramos o eliminaremos
nuestra tolerancia a la corrupción
saliéramos de esta zona que se debate
entre sí mismo y la resignación y
ejerciéramos nuestra función de
ciudadanos recuperando la indignación
frente a la corrupción movilizándonos
fiscalizando la función pública y sobre
todo ejerciendo un voto responsable para
no elegir a personas sospechosas de
corrupción sin duda alguna se podría
hacer una diferencia sustancial es el
momento para que los buenos funcionarios
públicos ejerzan su liderazgo integridad
y se enfrenten a los funcionarios
corruptos que los empresarios aporten
desde su perspectiva del sector
con todo el potencial que eso trae y que
los ciudadanos organizados también
ejerzamos de alguna manera nuestra
obligación de asegurarnos que
construimos y somos capaces de construir
un país mejor un perú que sea más justo
donde haya menos desigualdad y donde
todos sin distinción alguna podamos
realizar nuestros sueños otros lo han
hecho nosotros también podríamos hacerlo
gracias
[Aplausos]